so quick supplement on to the one i did
on they them pronouns because i had more
to say than i could in that one minute
so
the main thing that kind of causes the
issue with they them pronouns in english
is that in this language
in specific we don't have a
gender-neutral
singular pronoun now other languages do
but since we don't it causes
issues and confusion that's not to say
that they don't exist
they actually do there are a number of
them out there some of them even in use
like say for instance
zizer but they are not universally
agreed upon within the language because
that's not something you can force
i mean first of all don't claim that
they're made up all words are made up
that's how language works
but words come into common parlance
through usage and basically the culture
not as a body like voting on it but just
through use collectively becomes part of
the popular
cultural conscience and we haven't
gotten there yet with any of the
singular gender neutral pronouns maybe
we will i'd like to see it in my
lifetime but we're not there yet